les drapeaux sont hissés à les greens
coupé au millimètre et les joueurs sont
arrivés tout est prêt pour accueillir ce
jeudi 28 juin la 102e édition de l'open
de france sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
pendant quatre jours les joueurs ont
juste à jouer jouez bien le parcours est
super dont eux ils ont des surfaces de
jeu fantastique maintenant on attend un
beau vainqueur des manchois le futur
vainqueur pourrait se nommer justin
thomass le numéro 2 mondial sera
considéré comme le favori de l'épreuve
pour sa première sur le tournoi
l'américain veut gagner pour préparer la
future ryder cup 2018 qui se tiendra sur
le même parcours
une décision qui pourrait ravir le
capitaine de l'équipe américaine jim
furyk
il a compris qu'il y avait des choses à
mettre en place des stratégies à faire
pour préparer notre corps et notre jeu à
la saison évidemment la ryder cup pour
moi mais il ya d'autres tournois jusqu'à
la ryder cup
j'ai essayé de faire le meilleur
planning pour ma part du côté les
français le numéro à alexander levy 27
ans va tenter de décrocher sa
qualification pour la ryder cup en
remportant son premier open de france
pour mettre toutes ses chances de son
côté le varroa analysé le parcours
on a passé six heures sur le parcours a
vraiment essayé de le planifier au mieux
de mettre plein de stratégie et pouvoir
bien m'entraîner a joué intelligemment
ce parcours alexander levy devoir
répondre présent dès ce jeudi 28 juin à
8 heures il lancera les hostilités sur
cet open de france 2018 avec justin
thomas c'est le vainqueur de l'an passé
tommy fil twitter